There is some very important vaccine news today.
Now, as a reset reminder, Donald Trump promised
one hundred million vaccine doses
being distributed by October 31st.
That deadline came and went. We don't know right
now the real vaccine timeline. Hopefully Joe
Biden's new coronavirus task force, which is being
formed today or this week, will get us realistic
information about that. But tremendous news from
Pfizer, which is one of the companies working on
a coronavirus vaccine. Pfizer announced today that
its vaccine is more than 90 percent effective at
preventing coronavirus based on data from
a large study. If accurate, it has not yet
been peer reviewed, but it will be if accurate.
This would be groundbreaking. We've been thinking,
you know, the vaccine, at least the initial
vaccine, it might only be 40 percent effective,
a number closer to 90. We are talking about a game
changer here. The stock market exploding today.
If 40 percent of the country
still doesn't want the vaccine,
that's a problem no matter what. But no matter
what, you want a 90 percent effective vaccine
over a 40 percent effective vaccine any day.
Pfizer and its German partner, bio tech,
are the first drug makers to show successful
data from these large scale clinical trials.
They've found no safety concerns and they expect
to seek emergency use in. The US later this month,
now, you might remember Donald Trump was
encouraging manufacturers to seek emergency use
because Trump was desperate to get his
FDA to just approve whatever so Trump
can say he got the vaccine. In either case,
the vaccine has nothing to do with Trump.
Manufacturers said we will not seek authorization
before it is actually the right thing to do. The
new expectation is authorization requests may come
this month. The number of doses will initially be
limited. Many questions remain about how long are
you immune? But there is no doubt that this is
absolutely huge. Pfizer said the interim data
was conducted after ninety four participants
got the virus, which allowed them to see how many
of the people who got it had the vaccine versus
placebo. This is how you start figuring out how
effective it is. We don't yet have the full data.
It will be released soon and peer reviewed.
I don't believe Pfizer would make this up,
but it does have to be peer reviewed
now in terms of production to save time.
Companies have already started manufacturing
vaccines because if you wait until you know
for sure it works and it will be approved,
you're behind by months on vaccine production,
Pfizer expects 50 million doses this year,
two doses per person. That would be for
twenty five million people, just under 10 percent
of the country. Pfizer says it will produce
one point three billion doses in twenty twenty
one good for about six hundred and fifty million
people to get both doses. The CEO also said to
Dr. Sanjay Gupta of CNN that the vaccine will be
free to all Americans. Donald Trump desperate
to grasp for any relevance he can find
tweeting this morning saying, quote, In all
caps, stock market up, big vaccine coming soon,
report 90 percent effective. Such great news. Now,
of course, what's hilarious and almost starting
to get sad is that the stock market is up. Yes,
partially because of the vaccine, partially
because of the predicted stability of a Biden
administration and the removal of Trump. And of
course, the vaccine has nothing to do with Donald
Trump whatsoever. But he wants us to think it does
have something to do with him because he plans,
according to Rudy Giuliani and others, to continue
making the case that he's not only been a good
president, but that he really won reelection and
that he should remain president. That's a separate
story. Trump is old news. Let's hope that with
Joe Biden coming in and creating a task force,
vaccine development will continue going forward.
The next few months are going to be ugly
regardless. And I actually want to commend Joe
Biden because Joe Biden, instead of tweeting in
all caps, vaccine vaccine, we got it. Everything's
great. Joe Biden already showing the type of
leadership he will provide on the virus, put out
a sober and insane statement about this, saying
he was advised last night of the vaccine news, but
that it's important to understand that the virus
is going to continue for months, that the battle
will continue for months, that the announced
timeline is an approval in late November, that if
that's achieved and some Americans start getting
vaccinated, it will still be months before there
is widespread vaccination. That's exactly right.
Trump just tweets in all caps. We got a vaccine.
This is why Joe Biden goes on to say, The
CDC warned that for the foreseeable future,
people have to wear masks. The news of the vaccine
doesn't change that. Americans must rely on masks,
distancing, tracing, washing and other
measures to stay safe. The news is great,
but it doesn't change the fact.
And a thousand people a day are still
dying. There's definitely more than a thousand
people a day lying about Trump's successes. But
more than a thousand people a day are tragically
dying of the virus. That is how you actually
manage expectations. Not telling us we are
moments from a vaccine for six months, which is
what Donald Trump did. Good for Joe Biden. We will
disagree with Joe Biden on policy, of course, as
we start to see him do stuff once he is president.
I am very reassured by that type of message
on the virus that sanity is returning.
And that's a really, really good thing.